and there was a little cholito dude and
his old lady took the baby inside he's
trying to fold up the stroller in front
of me like my windshield is like the
movie screen and this dude is looking
around trying to find the lever that
collapses the stroller
so I'm watching him and it's funny
because it's turning and the wheels are
turning and he can't figure it out and
she's knocking on the window and he's
like wait and I rolled the window down
and I said to him I said you are right
man he turns or he looks at me goes I
just wanted my dick suck
hello everyone hola Mis Amigos you're
listening to oh my God
hola With Me George
is
you know George's oh I'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
George Lopez George Lopez oh my God omg
omg
oh my God
hindsight is 2020 and you can't change
the past but what if you could get a
Little Help from your future self maybe
you'd ask to borrow a little cash
now you can with Dave Dave is banking
app that can help you get up to 500
instantly with extra cash that's more
money to fill your tank buy a wedding
gift or catch up on bills there's no
interest and no credit check download
Dave from the App Store now that's
d-a-v-e and sign up for extra cash
account and get up to five hundred
dollars instantly instant transfer fees
apply
or it sucks when you go to when you're
looking at a fun house mayor and you
look better and yeah and you're like
[ __ ] I just
you know curve up where are you guys
next week oh yeah this is a better angle
there you go uh do we have any beer you
have beer you drink I don't drink at all
not at all good are you Muslim no I just
don't drink it's never happened
I know yeah it's Gotta Be So extreme
I'm not muzzling my drink yeah
no but you just never had a taste for it
I never had a taste for it I just never
did I just we I know actually I just
recently started like using it to like a
little CBD like weed mix but like very
slow very small the most I'll do is like
one four and that's like 20 right and I
actually like that I got some gummies
too you sleep with it or do you so yeah
sometimes I have these like uh these
this new companies called five CBD so
it'll be like 25 milligrams no I'm sorry
five milligrams of of THC and then the
rest is CBD take that and it's chill I
don't like being high I don't like that
feeling
it you know God this is so different now
then
it used to be when we went out we used
to see how [ __ ] up we could get yeah
like nobody there's no no limit let's
see like you have a dude and he's like
between cars you know
[Applause]
and it's just like there was no
there's no social anything to it no
social stigma I know but I used to be
around I mean I was around a lot of
people that used to like you know really
get blitzed you know what I mean but um
what else you got you got some water can
I get some water
it's gonna look terrible like what else
do you have it's fine has this been
running do you want any water do we have
water
um
yeah do you want sparkling or yeah I
better get sparkling so I don't feel
fancy nobody had sparkling either like
yeah but drinking it tastes like alcats
when I was a kiss
not until recently so much man I was at
a 1999 party one of those uh yeah one of
those you know in 1999 yeah when it was
gonna turn yeah everybody the world was
going to end right I was at a New Year's
party and that was when I really decided
for sure I was never gonna drink and
growing up did you drink no not at all
do your mom drink no did your dad drink
no I know I'll never met my dad thanks
for bringing that up you never met your
dad I never met my dad yeah isn't that
weird
did you ever try
um
you know what man it's a crazy thing
like
first of all like do you have pictures
of your dad no I haven't I don't even
know I don't have any pictures of my dad
yeah I got paintings in my dead
paintings how old are you [ __ ]
oh my my dad as a result
of a documentary of the [ __ ] paint
yeah don't move yeah if that was picture
they did a portrait uh there was a
documentary that dropped on Netflix no
you know Gil's background no you don't
oh I love I love telling [ __ ] people
do it oh perfect so gill
now I feel like I'm you know I'm one of
the gangs it's got to be the craziest
name for water
liquid death
come stain cheers
um cheers
uh okay
um
will you stop looking at yourself I
really got it do you see where I'm
looking I'm looking over here yeah I
know I get it over there uh Gil
introduce yourself to Eric Griffin
Gil Carrillo uh friend with George now
George I Met George because he had
watched the podcast about your about you
not me there was a pot there was a
four-part documentary on not Netflix
about a case that I was involved in the
Night Stalker case oh right right now I
you know what I'm caught I know now
sorry are you into crime as well yes yes
yes yes why is everybody into what
everybody loves fascinating you know why
because I think that people are
inherently good
um and when people aren't
we we are fascinated by that psychopath
psychology you know like I like I can
forgive anyone our crime that they do
right it's how it's how they act in the
aftermath right that's the psychopath I
uh
you know in my house I got a bunch of
Junior detectives you know everybody
wants to solve the crime they watch it I
know who did it this is how they yeah
how they did it and uh the guys that do
it
I understand why they did what they did
I don't condone what they did right but
I just understand it makes a lot easier
to talk let me ask you a question though
yes two questions sure
that's fascinating what you just said
because to me it means like do you think
it's important to understand the mind of
the people that you're chasing after
meaning like you have to find that
connection to be like I know why they
did this is that does that help you in
trying to figure out who they are where
they are how they did it why they did it
immensely I need to know I they did they
they stabbed a kid 75 times
I need to have the understand why did
they do that you know and that what was
their motivation to do that and that
that in fact was a sexual deviate so now
I know I'm looking for a sexual deviance
what helps me along in the case not is
there any part of you that like got a
connection to it in a sense that like
not that you felt the same thing that
they felt but was there ever a time
where like it was messing with you you
know what I mean like like to really
like get it like to get into the mind of
a killer is there any part of you that
like tapped into your own self to being
like could I do this could I be a killer
well I I did talk to the shrink at one
time while we were going through trial
uh because I had to ask the shrink is it
wrong for me to I have dreams of how I'm
gonna kill these guys while we're in
trial right and so the only thing that
kept me from doing it is every scenario
in my mind where I know what I wanted to
do I was always going to get caught
and it was wrong I didn't want to so I
didn't have the well you didn't want to
get caught I didn't want to sound to me
like if if they said you're not going to
get if there was a scenario give me a
freebie you had a freebie if I had if I
had a freebie maybe because yeah I have
been involved in you know this type of
work and before that I had been in
combat Vietnam
so man so thank you for your service
thank you it's so it's just a matter of
you do what you got to do you know and
you just don't panic at it and so I
could never get out of life I feel like
I'm interviewing you guys this is so
fascinating what I find interesting
about about Gil is that there's a
mandatory retirement in the sheriff's uh
office right or in law enforcement used
to be used to be no no longer state law
to change it in in whatever in whatever
position anybody has that you spend 40
years on a job and then you're there and
you enjoy your job and then for some
whatever reason wherever you work
you know coming up hey uh when you turn
67 bill is mandatory retire you have to
retire but he loves his job he loves
what he does and where do you go when
you turn 67 plus one day yeah where do
you go for the rest of your life a lot
of dudes pass away man because it's it's
a cycle of your life you have some place
that when you have nowhere to go in real
life like you could say you can choose
not to go someplace or choose to do this
or that but when you get to the age in
your life where and usually it gets
sadder as you get older it really it
does yeah I can say you guys are going
to go through the same thing right now
the public needs you you know you
satisfy their their need their want to
laugh the comedy that you guys put on
and you have crowds that pay money to go
see you you think I sell it did you
interrupt because you thought I was
going to a place where it was going to
be boring no no no no because of the
thing but but also
you still have value to
to provide this [ __ ] intelligence
that you have that all of a sudden a
company says you you know right thank
you yeah you know but how about this
taking about what how you were what
you're talking about I say
This Is Why We Shouldn't Define
ourselves by what we do ah or that's
because what it because and that's what
we kind of learned in the pandemic you
know like for a long time I Define I'm a
comic you know I'm an actor I'm a this
and when they got taken away we had to
look at ourselves and go well who are
who am I now then you come to find out
actually you're more than that you're
also a husband a brother a son a father
a friend or you're like you find Hobbies
you find and I think that's important
too to be a a well-rounded person in the
event that what you love and your
passion gets taken away listen
I started doing stand-up
June 4th of 1979.
I never thought I would live to to see
the day where a comedian would make
sense about how a [ __ ] person's life
should be he's right it's hard to think
that a committee and this was one of the
things I wanted to ask you it's hard to
think that a comedian thinks rationally
we think we have to come from a place
where we're in pain and you do it
because you suffer you've just separated
yourself from the art where like you
said why do why do we have to do it so
it defines us a lot of times I ask
myself because I've been doing it for so
long that there is a bit of um
of a shield up where are you without
that shield and maybe
like I rarely go out like I was doing
this movie and the days I didn't work or
most of the time I just stayed in and
I'm just kind of used to staying there
but I think even at my age I'm still
trying to really figure out
what a what am I if I were to retire
like as you said what am I without all
of
all of the things gone and the guy who I
talked to my therapist said you chose
things that you can do singularly I
would grew up in only child I spent a
lot of time I was only child two I have
a golf and I play guitar both you could
do and you pick stand up but you need an
audience but you can travel alone so you
pick the things that are singular in a
life in a world filled with people you
chose the things that isolate you but I
think that that Shield that you put up
isn't a shield from I think it's a
shield more uh up from protecting
against like really taking your feelings
you know out like like I'm dealing now
with my therapist about about what would
it look like if I didn't
compartmentalize you know and it's like
that because that's what we do we
compartmentalize our lives because like
let's say you're going on a road trip
you or you know so you you can't be
thinking about
all the stuff that's going on in my life
because I gotta I have to be on point
because I'm doing these shows that's
right so you compartmentalize but what
happens when like I always I always
think when you're compartmentalize it's
like a TV dinner you know so you have
your salisbury steak and you got to do
this so that's what you do but what
happens when that TV dinner gets shaken
up and stuff starts to spill into other
areas we Shield ourselves because we
don't want to deal with those emotions
and feelings that go with that and so
that's what we learn to do especially
when you're like it's like well I'm solo
too as an only child but even your
example like you said you play the
guitar by yourself because you can but
you know what it sounds like when you
have a guitar with another guitar and
some drums and a thing it just expands
it it makes it even more beautiful and
so I don't know I just feel like and I
think also that like I I we we are we
rationalize things because we're trying
to find the funny you know what I mean
we're trying to find the the this is you
know these are the things but it's still
very a deep deep thought process that
brings emotions that we don't want to
deal with you know so so Eric you know
Eric uh
um in in the years of my travel and
stuff like you become a very good
auditory processor you know hearing wise
where you can hear somebody and know
exactly
their depth or or their connection to an
audience and when I started the Laugh
Factory and I saw you doing stand-up I
had to go and look because I I said this
dude has got a great mind and this dude
is really funny and the stuff that he's
talking about is really
out of the norm and I was just like wow
man yeah man yeah you know like you know
I see I see a bunch of or or if you
don't watch it but when you hear it it's
going to grab your attention it's like a
car you know when somebody starts a car
and you hear the engine you're like oh
[ __ ] what you got in there and that's
where I felt when I saw you I appreciate
that and but you know it's like it's
hard to watch Comedy when you're a comic
right you know especially uh someone
that you have been in you know how many
generations of Comedy have you been in
have you seen the evolution of
you know so after a while you go man
okay you see someone and you go they
might they're entertaining this is funny
but like I don't want to watch this
right now because it's like I know
what's happening right you know so you
know what I mean you just kind of uh I
mean how many friends do you have or
like people you know in comedy where
have you really sat down and watched
them like like like of people that you
know personally how many times have you
watched them do an hour right I would
say I have lifelong friends in comedy
that I've never watched them do an hour
yeah
but sometimes I feel like we should
sometimes it's rare to live you know you
sit and watch your friends heart how did
you become
um did you become a stand-up a fan of
stand up and a fan of Comedy
before here yes oh yes yes I like I said
first time I came here I had paid at
least four or five times to see you yeah
do stand up I've been uh Dom Herrera I
remember that's the first comedian
that's first stand-up comedian I'd ever
seen that was years ago uh up in
Hollywood uh but I love stand up yeah
you know I love anything I love stand up
or anything that's gonna make me laugh
right laugh laughter is this is good for
this so because of you oh go ahead so no
go ahead I was gonna say so because of
the things that you've done and do I bet
I would venture to say you probably a
great comedy audience member because
like you know like the things that like
Society takes serious about comedy right
now you probably look and just go what
the [ __ ] is wrong with you guys there's
actually real [ __ ] going on I deal with
murderers and killers and rapists and
these kinds of things and you guys are
mad at a comic yeah so you probably are
just you probably like the darker stuff
too when you watch it all right I love
dark dirty even clean yeah of course but
I'm saying you appreciate it I do
appreciate what they do and there is
nobody in that audience that'll laugh
louder than me and I people say I have a
contagious laugh I laugh and I get going
and it's funny they're for you you know
it used to be rare to see you know it's
funny because you know there is a kind
of a
a female comedians like when I was when
I in the 80s you know there wasn't a lot
of female comedians and very few of them
there were writers you know now they
produce shows and they create shows and
all that stuff so yeah the evolution of
it has been good but you know
um
they you know they have so much to say
man that's so funny and you know we we
bring them in here and the thing that I
like even for me is because you don't
see it is when they come in and they
have a different point of view that it's
really refreshing for for he and I to
see it well you know what that is that's
about perspective man yeah and that's
the thing that's the that's the
difference it's like you know when you
think about I think one of the things
that made Seinfeld so funny the show
yeah was that they had some strong
female writers who were riding for
Elaine right you know so it was for
Elaine from a female perspective that's
right you know so then as a guy we don't
know what that perspective is in the
same way that like a white guy may not
understand the Latino's perspective and
like you know and so they they're
they're sitting there writing you know
you know and it's like it's it's
different you know so it is refreshing
you just gotta sit down and go oh you
know what I never thought of it like
that right that's what comedy's supposed
to be for so so
um did you you went to UCLA you took
classes in stand up in comedy yeah yeah
I did well that you know my mom's very
supportive like that uh if I you know so
let's go back to you you know I would I
would have imagined you were from
someplace else I'm from L.A I was born
and raised in La uh only child single
mom you know she's uh you know uh uh I'm
a first-born American my mom's from
Central America you know so we have my
family's from like I have family from
Belize Jamaica Honduras you know I saw
it's like it's a hodgepodge of things
right you know so because through there
different nationalities and different
things I was in uh bro people don't
people don't I always say people want to
know what you are so they can know how
to hate you you know and so for me I've
had I've always just been like it is
what it is you know so I'm like you know
so I'm like uh I I should say I identify
as black
yeah yeah but that's just uh I know it's
just a small percentage of and it's also
because of how I grew up I grew up in a
mostly black neighborhood uh ghetto
adjacent you know so that's where was
that where was that in L.A like off like
uh near Pico and La Brea you know like
remember Okie dogs oh yeah you grew up
around there yeah mid uh mid what's they
called midtown midtown midtown okay it's
all gone Fairfax no it was Okie Dog on
Pico it was an original Okie dog I
should drive RTD bus up Pico yes
I was a Jackie Gleason before I became a
cop I drove for three months they gave
me my welcome aboard speech and I said
thank you very much I'll give you my two
week notice because I'm going you didn't
like it oh you're welcome no I was going
to the department that's the only job
that ever really gave me nightmares
and again driving a bus they got to put
the driver at the back of the [ __ ]
bus you can't be driving with your
[ __ ] back turn yeah not to those
animals
what's the craziest [ __ ] you saw oh I
had uh my nieces I didn't see it my
[ __ ] was like three rows of
teeth that [ __ ] YouTube thing no
they're sitting there and he's kind of
like this ain't like a three rows of
teeth he's just [ __ ] looking straight
ahead you're like God damn [ __ ] bus
my wife took two of her nieces on the
bus just to ride with me to see what it
was like on the bus and she was scared
[ __ ] when she got she saw some guys
robbing people on the bus you know
taking them taking [ __ ] out they sound
pickpocketing then they just saw him
playing Jack somebody and but I saw
everything I I drove a bus uh through
East L.A you know same but 26 line down
to Broadway out to Pico and then out
Pico to rinpaw and then turn around
right at Midtown Center
and at one o'clock in the morning they'd
get on on First Street and it's a it's a
standing load full of drunks that can't
stand
and but I didn't give a [ __ ] hey come on
you know you're they're all Mexicans
they're all getting on they get on a
brand one guy was drunk they all knew
that because it's a regular run for me
they'd get on he was drunk he fell down
and then he started cussing me out and
when he started cussing me out
the other passengers who you know they'd
hide their banks that don't hide it go
back there I don't give a [ __ ] if you're
drinking
pulled over the next stop they said open
the door they got him and they threw his
ass out and once they threw his ass out
everybody started cheering he said let's
go yeah so they and then you get your
two weeks yeah and then I get my I gave
my two weeks is it more dangerous than
Vietnam no no there's nothing that could
be like Vietnam man that you know what
the funny what you just did
in a comedy setting that would be
hilarious
you know what I mean that was the
commenting you took over for a second
and then you caught yourself like
actually we're having a serious
conversation yeah there's no way but it
was like you know what I mean listen man
I would have [ __ ] bet I would have
buried myself under the [ __ ] tents in
Vietnam I'm a [ __ ] cop I would have
not listen
you've performed for the troops right I
have God bless you because I did what I
could give back God bless you thank you
you know what I remember I did it too a
couple times thank you yeah but I
remember being out there and that's like
you know they it was like dinner time
and they said what they wanted us to do
was like Hey Comics don't sit together
just mingle out with the troops like go
sit in the thing yeah and they and you
just like damn they just wanted to feel
yeah you know I I don't know I just I
don't know
where I was the only what we used to
call Round eye people from the USA the
only round-eyed group I saw were the
Beach Boys
I got to see they came to where we were
one time and they put on a show they got
all [ __ ] up I remember the drummer
grabbing the Sims walking around and
paying and banging you know with the
guys out there it was it was awesome did
you see Apocalypse Now yes I did the the
the redo I saw the original when they
brought the when they brought the
Playboy mate the Playboy girls to to
entertain the troops yeah those dudes
went crazy yeah I didn't see you know
like Bob Hope and God hope God blessed
something for everything he did with his
troop but they all went to Big bases
where they could secure everything well
yeah and and they had to
for Just Cause but I was never fortunate
enough to be around a big place like
that to be able to go see it the Beach
Boys I don't know who paid him off to do
what they said he got blown every day
Bob Hope God bless him that's why he
wanted to be away from home
go get a blow bath and a steam job for
America
wait is it right hat is that right I got
a hold of her head with this one I hold
him remember being a little frightened
like landing and wherever we were I
think it was in Bosnia or something you
know and then like you know we're in
this like Hummer you know and then
there's like one behind one in front and
I'm like hey what's going on they're
like oh that's security and then in that
moment I thought we need security you
know yeah that's that moment I was like
well oh man what does this mean you know
what does this mean that we need
security is there a is there a chance
that something you know and you just I
guess you just don't want to think about
that you just want to like I'm just here
I'm trying to like spread some Joy yeah
I don't know I don't know what people's
motivation is sometimes so I heard when
I used to go to Walter Reed you know in
the early 2000s or mid-2000s and they
would say that in Vietnam I mean it's
kind of a crazy subject when somebody
got blown up they they passed they they
pat they died but then you had the armor
in these dudes so they would lose their
limbs like their legs but but survive
because this was protected more so than
it was in Vietnam you guys didn't have
those things and so they would die and
these dudes would live but they would
live they give us you know I was up I
was flying helicopters they gave us
armor plating and I wouldn't wear it I'd
sit on it because we're up in here I
didn't want somebody shoot me in the
nuts so we'd sit on our [ __ ] rather than
have it up here because without these I
ain't no [ __ ] good
I'm no good I have them and I don't use
them the uh the uh but I'm sure you put
them to a good use over there they're
only there for they're decorative I'm
sure they're like for you they're like a
57 Chevy that's right they'll be at the
car show
so so let me ask you this
um I remember I said was was it was it
uh I don't know if it was maybe
Valentine's Day I saw a post that you
had and you look very very happy man
yeah I just got married I know but you
know congratulations really happy yeah
and I thought wow man how great that
this couple looks really happy yeah I
know it I I didn't know I got married
and I didn't realize what I was missing
until it what until I was in it you know
even though we together six years and
all that I mean I regret it I regret not
thinking more how important it is to
like fall in love start a family and all
this kind of stuff when I was younger I
just was so focused on you know trying
to make it and yeah and being hurt
before and then being closed off right
because now I'm spreading the word to
like a young man I'm saying to them you
know here's a question I was asked a
young dude who's like in a relationship
but I was like hey you want to get
married they're like hey I don't know
I'm you know I'm doing my thing uh you
know right I just go well how old do you
want to be when your kid is 10.
oh my God that's right that's what I
asked him how old do you want to be when
your kid is 10. do these speeches as
part of the church or uh
all right you know I forgot about I even
forgot about that that's what I'm saying
but she's like yeah so she's great I
mean she's really like I I I'm enjoying
this so so so so it's making me work out
more now it's making me like myself you
lost a lot yeah I'm trying to lose more
weight I'm trying to be healthy because
I want to last you know what I mean
because now I just turned 50 and I just
got married you know so it's crazy yeah
would you have done you you had hurt you
had hurts and relationships that have
gone bad before yeah have you ever been
close to being married and then no no
that's the thing too is like I never and
so then because of the being hurt one
time really bad that kind of like my my
thought process was like well that's it
let me just work on me and like you know
then you know it's such a solitary
business to be a comic to try to make it
through because it's about cultivating
these relationships it's about you know
it's so competitive like uh you know you
know and you're just you know you just
focus so much on yourself that you're
not even thinking about having somebody
to you know share this Joy with and you
know and all that stuff
the uh um
and is she is she a reporter
no no no no I wish
but you guys met uh we just actually we
met online you know it's just it's just
a casual thing and then and then she I
was like hey come once you come to my
show it's so funny
is the idea of a dating app crazy to go
back and think that
you where would you meet somebody like
in the back of them you were asking the
wrong guy about the massage in the back
of the pennies you know the back of the
I mean no this guy's old you you you you
mean
you meet at a bar you meet like uh or
somebody hooks you up and it's like look
I have no problem with people online
dating or meeting I just say to people
get off of it right away connect then
you you had the vetting process that's
what the apps are it's like you can go
through Facebook and be like all right
let me see where you went to school let
me see pictures of you but that's what
people need in a bar you should carry
around a dossier at a bar you know what
I mean take a look at it go over there
exactly you're like oh you went to
grammar school where this is cool and
then you could come back and be like hey
okay let's have a drink you know what I
mean that's for a picture of her mother
see what she's gonna look like all that
kind of stuff this is the kind of thing
you could do now online but anyway girl
you know she was a fan of uh like uh
this Showtime show I was on I'm dying up
here you know what I mean so she like
then but she's beautiful so she liked
three of my pictures and and follow me
so a guy like me that's sliding into the
DMS
so I so I sent her a message and it was
so funny because she was like I wanna uh
she was like she was I said well I have
a show she was like well I'm actually
already going to a comedy show and I was
like well just come to my show I'll get
you in and then she was like well I you
know she didn't want to tell me this she
already had a date with a guy and he was
taking her to a comedy show so what she
did is she she switched it she said to
the guy hey why don't we go to this
comedy show ah you know what I mean
so I'm on stage and I'm doing jokes
about how I'm not going to be your
friend you know
write to her and this poor idiot sitting
behind her doesn't realize that I'm you
know and then uh
I went to a that I I met her she hit me
up one night was like hey I'm at this uh
bar Delilah's because they had live
music playing and her friend was playing
like she had a friend this dude who was
playing it's on it's on Santa Monica
it's on Santa Monica near like Crescent
Heights a little around there you've
seen it yeah and so but something
happened like like she she was they were
interested in each other but the guy
invited like four other girls okay so
and so she hit me up like hey you want
to come over here to try to like but
then we hit it off we went outside
started talking next thing you know we
started going on dates wow cut two boom
here we are six years later married
congratulations yeah did did
um
you guys but well at what point do you
say
to yourself I think I'm I think I'm
gonna ask her to marry me
you know it's like it's different now I
guess because like you know we had one
breakup you know and then when we were
gonna get back together she just made it
very clear she was like listen I want a
family I want to you know boom and I was
like I know you know and so I know that
get us getting back together it needs to
lead to that yes so we were already on
the road to that it just and you were
all right with that yes me saying let's
get back together it was me
acknowledging to her I want the same
thing too and we're going to work
towards my mind cuts too in my comedy
head back to the future when the car
takes off and they're just fire burning
where the rubber was the [ __ ] car is
already gone you just see a little bit
but that fire like it said you know if
we get back together again this is going
to lead to I want kids
you know and I try another message I'm
trying to tell young men you know 20
late 20s 30s don't be afraid if a woman
who say 26
says I kind of I want to have kids in a
family because it's different from women
at 26 how long does it take I always ask
people tell me the timeline you tell I'm
gonna ask you this question you tell me
the timeline how long does it take for
someone to meet fall in love get married
and have kids give me the timeline six
years
so if she's starting at 26 I say is six
years a good number I think it's six
years but then she gonna be 32 yeah she
don't got time for you to be [ __ ]
around right so I always tell young men
don't be afraid when a girl just says
hey if she says even in the first week
where you find it from on stage what
um when you do your therapy people go
people will say three years four years
you know it's in that range but it's in
the right range but I even say that's
why women are asking this question
because if they're let's say they're 28
they're saying hey this is my Prime I
need to know I can't be sitting around
with you for five years while you trying
to start your band and do your podcast
and then you leave did you leave me
right you know what I mean so it's
different you know we can we're man we
can have kids at a later age it's not
the same so that's why people need to
have these conversations I think it's
important for people to be like you know
hey what what what what's your future
look like and then you know and so you
can know don't waste time you think
that's a tough conversation to have or
or I think it's I don't know man I I'm
from a different era yeah I think that
that conversation scares I know dudes
that
but also but also you have men and women
so the women want to be they want to be
wives and they want to be mothers yeah
not all of them but you say the ones
that do well that's that's crazy how
that's frowned upon is it isn't it crazy
how it's found like if there is a person
who was like to me the most important
thing in the world is to raise kids you
know and to be there for them right but
that's but then you have a certain
segment of people who are saying like no
girl go get your career think about you
know it's like no there's some women who
are like no I wanna be at home and raise
my kids and that's somehow for some
people that's looked upon as like some
bad thing so when my daughter was with
my daughter mine was was little uh um
you know my wife was the dominant uh man
in the relationship and uh
she goes inside to go find out about
yeah she gave you a ribs
and there was a little cholito dude and
his old lady took the baby inside and
he's trying to fold up the stroller in
front of me like my windshield is like
the movie screen and this dude is
looking around trying to find the lever
that collapses the stroller
so I'm watching them and it's funny
because it's turning and the wheels are
turning and he can't figure it out and
she's knocking on the window and he's
like wait and I roll the window down and
I said to him I said you are right man
he turns or he looks at me goes I just
wanted my dick suck
[Laughter]
dick suck and I thought Look at me now
Look at Me
Baby like come on I can't figure it out
oh I was like all about living up living
up to your responsibility the moment of
just that dude was just so frustrated
with that [ __ ] Emerson [ __ ] model
number stroller so so but you did all
right you yeah
your daughter is working with you now
you you your daughter's in the business
now working alongside you how does that
feel
um I don't know man I can't tell you
she's cool you know what my daughter's
cool man I mean
a little bit of a mother winner wow
what I mean she's her mom too her mom
you never met Anne have you yeah I did
oh man
great
this is the realest moment
she treated me real nice
you could thank me for that
I'm paying her to teach you that though
but but but
um the idea of it is wait is there a
backstory here I don't know about it
I think I just made one yeah instead of
me like you're instead of me like he's
married to your ex-wife
Microsoft oh yeah
so it was all very nice
well one thing I never did was say for a
rainy day so I think you know back then
there wasn't cash apps like uh Dave so
you know you could get money but people
it always comes at the wrong time it's
almost like when you say to somebody
like whenever you're in a hurry there's
always traffic but whenever you need
some money the things come you know like
it says wedding gift or a gas or a bill
that you know or insurance I remember I
always struggled to pay my insurance and
even though I worked I could have used
the app like Dave where you go just let
me get my insurance covered then I'll be
over sure yeah and then it's always more
than you thought it was
and then that's what I think this app is
for that at that time where you say all
right
sometimes you just need to reach out for
help I mean we've all been in a
situation at some point in our lives
when we're a little tight on cash maybe
you could only afford a few gallons of
gas in your tank and then you got to
save up and you're wondering how you're
going to get through it to afford a gift
and all that and that's why I think the
Dave app helps if you're living paycheck
to paycheck which you know come on after
the pandemic a lot of people are doing a
lot of people who are successful do it
and you're struggling to make ends meet
it can really be stressful when
unexpected expenses come up now Dave can
help you get out of a pinch when you
really need it Dave is a banking app
that can help you get up to 500
instantly with extra cash that's more
money to fill your tank buy a wedding
gift or catch up on bills you can
finally tackle those expenses that have
been stressing you out without any
Hang-Ups there's no interest and no
credit check needed millions of people
have already downloaded the Dave app to
get financial relief they need with
extra cash so if you're in a pinch and
need some extra help download Dave and
think of it as a helping hand I think in
the big world like you you know if you
have an app like this and people get
money and it's not it doesn't tax you
and you get you know they're going to
get a little they're gonna get their
money back that it is almost like
somebody you can rely on right if you
had a friend you could always go to and
say Hey you know help me out of this of
this thing download the Dave app from
the app store right now that's d-a-v-e
sign up for an extra cash account and
get up to 500 instantly
for terms and conditions go to the
dave.com slash legal
instant transfer fees apply banking
provided by evolve remember
FDIC future you will thank you
what relationship do you have with uh
Richard Pryor as a comedian
um I I came at a point where
I mean technology is so different right
now right so you got like you can see
everything now yeah at that time you
really couldn't see a lot of how that
was yeah right so for me like the person
that really inspired me more was Eddie
Murphy yeah so to me I saw Richard
Powers through the lens of Eddie Murphy
right you know and it wasn't until later
that I was like oh this is what Richard
Pryor was about and to me
when I think about Richard Pryor I don't
necessarily think about Richard Pryor
the comedian I think about Richard Pryor
the comedian activist just coming up at
a time when the world was so you
couldn't say this you couldn't say that
white versus black minorities and all
that so and how he was like a
visionarian that way you know but in
terms of like for like art and that kind
of thing I didn't look at it like that
you know I just didn't yeah I was more I
was I was more in line with like how
Eddie Murphy was this like performer
right it's funny that um
it wasn't looked at as a performance per
se it's like like as a set you know you
don't look at live in Long Beach as you
know one of the best recorded
performances of standard right or
whatever you know you don't you don't
you didn't look at it like that
you know when when you went to The
Comedy Store and you would see
uh David Letterman or you would see or
Eddie Murphy would go in there or
um you know Howie Mandel or all those
other guys that were just you know
they're iconic now but then I remember
standing in front of The Comedy Store
seeing those guys come in and out like
nothing like you know like yeah because
there was a uh
another community that just died within
the last year there was a big activist
uh Dick Gregory Dick Gregory
and
I can't compare Dick Gregory to Richard
Richard in the same thing
but to me he wasn't as aggressive as
Dick Gregory and he was hilarious he was
a killer everything and he talked about
real life
uh not so anti
one way or another he he was good and I
love when Eddie Murphy when we were when
Eddie Murphy got his Mark Twain award we
all went to that Italian restaurant in
DC uh I forget what it's called Uh yeah
so we're all in the back room
and did gregories there and Chappelle's
there I think Chris Rock and everybody's
there Arsenio and and Trevor no all the
guys there and Dick Gregory talks for 40
minutes straight about healing and about
the powers of the body and it's just
going on her like he never runs out of
things to say
and Chappelle's standing up and Dick
Gregory says there's a doctor in Africa
that has a cure for every ailment that
the human body can have
and then Chappelle goes does he have a
card
it's like give me his car
but he just just into the in between the
sentences does he have a card because if
he can fix everything we want that
[ __ ] we want his card yeah
shouldn't we be calling him yeah yeah
but um yeah he he was just funny how
when you get older is when you get into
like vitamins and taking care of
yourself and like you don't need to you
don't know you need to take care of
yourself until you need to take care of
yourself he was making the most sense of
anything I've ever heard Dick Gregory
until the last 10 seconds he said and
then the dude took his glasses off and
green lights shot out of his eye socket
there was like
we went down that road you know who's
like that Farrakhan
Farrakhan will be talking and you'll
hear me be like okay maybe all right
yeah and then at the end and the Jews
then you're like
oh
man
come on man
shot out of his eyes you're like [ __ ]
um
somebody asked me what is the podcast
about I said whatever George whichever
way George godson to go did they did
they uh did they
um
settle with the vendors at Dodger
Stadium yes they did did you go to the
all-star game no I wish I would yeah
great game what sports are watching what
sports I'm in the basketball and
football baseball is just the D-League
is becoming quite a bit of a thing that
people should see huh it's over now but
yeah all the guys Shaq son and Scotty
Pippen's son and those young guys I find
that basketball has in the last year and
a half has risen in popularity and I
think it's because of all the off-season
stuff it needs personalities yeah man
baseball is just the most boring [ __ ]
you know Shaq and Charles Barkley have
made basketball interesting oh bro
they're great can I tell you something
sometimes I don't even watch the game
like I I uh record
yes yeah I don't even watch the game I
just go let me hear what they are
hilarious that's great
um
the the you know it's it's funny because
I saw Charles play and I saw Shaq play
um but the game now is a different
different game it's a different game
it's a different game but that's that's
what happens man the errors you know
through the areas of change look how
comedy comedy changes in the same way
you know what I mean man
the uh the um
the the identity of of teams too it's
like when the draft like they're all so
good that there isn't like a marquee
player that a team can have a team can
have guys and they're all [ __ ] great
instead of just having like a Michael
Jordan in Chicago well I don't know man
I don't know I don't know if I agree
with that I I really do think that
um we gravitate towards greatness and
and when you look at and that's what we
do we want people to rise to that
mountain and see if they can stay up
there and and that's what drives the
ratings right you know I mean LeBron
James just became a billionaire the
first active billionaire player in a
sport wow and so you know he's still at
age 38 and so who's gonna be the next
you know right we keep trying to do that
you know we have step we push Steph
Curry up there he like became the
greatest shooter ever we want that right
we want super teams we want to see those
we want to see them we want to see them
succeed and we want to see them taken
down yeah you know I don't think we want
because because if everybody's great
nobody's got nobody's great is the
baseball season too long I think it is I
know I just think baseball is just too
boring it's not a great TV Sport and the
[ __ ] things they're doing in between
like you had two minutes to get
yeah to start I I like the way they're
getting yeah if the the All-Star game
yesterday if it didn't tie score they're
gonna have a home run derby after the
game you know in order to break the nice
score it's just three guys from each
team and then and I thought one it's
like they don't have enough parody like
but the the the ratio isn't enough you
just have like it's becoming this sort
of regional sport you know yeah you know
like when they were gonna go on strike I
was laughing because I was like oh you
think people don't care if this doesn't
come back right no one's no no one cares
especially after cold
seasonings
prioritize what we find important if the
baseball if baseball was gonna be like
yeah we're gonna go on strike and you
think people are gonna be clamoring for
that they weren't what did you find out
about yourself during the pandemic I
found out that I can monetize my
personality in other ways other than
just being a stand-up comedian or actor
you know I started gaming on Twitch I
started like you know just getting into
different what's that tell me you're
talking about good gaming yeah I just
was like I play games every day on
Twitch Eric Griffin gaming that's what
I'm on all the time Eric Griffin gaming
so now I'm just the old man on there
gaming with people and so I find I can
monetize that I got like during the
pandemic I got all these opportunities
in gaming because I started doing that
because I was like the guy from
Workaholics now games and so I was like
oh so you could do other things if you
were into you were into gaming not yeah
but yeah but not like to think that oh
you could become a profession you know
you know what I mean so it's crazy you
know what that is gaming no expect you
know neither do I call it but I was
gonna put it on him
oh yeah I know what it is I gave my
twitch but twitch is just being on
Twitch it's just like a a a so when you
go on you alert all your followers yeah
yeah then it's on the gaming live
there's a little webcam picture of me
right they have professional stuff doing
that now yeah yeah because I remember
pandemic put a kibosh on a lot of it
because people they they but they were
Live Events and people were coming to
see people yeah do this yes there's
money to be made in a lot of different
areas now I mean this for instance has
changed comedy it really has it because
now we have a way to go direct to
Consumer hey fans here's me I'm being
funny here or I'm being serious or I'm
being whatever and it's direct too fast
so now we don't need to manufacture fans
in these other ways now you just have
this what do people like about this
podcast
[Laughter]
hard drive
but but
um it almost becomes the most honest
place to to speak because everything is
about changing yeah like they say Hey
you know get me this guy and then they
change you like like I think for stand
up I think even for stand-ups at a point
where I remember I saw Tim Allen in the
early 90s and everything that was in
Home Improvement was in his act like the
whole Tool Time and all that was in his
act well the show was based off that so
you so he started looking at guys and
you start thinking
is there anything that I have in my act
that would be comparable to that and I
did not I didn't have it so you stand
and you watch a guy that's the number
one TV show when it premieres and you
start thinking well [ __ ] maybe I don't
have the ability to create yeah showing
somewhere along the line I I found it
and you know that showed 20 years ago we
started it was you know until 2007. yeah
so I mean
to think back on the what I thought of
myself in the in 96
versus where I ended up in 206 it's kind
of wild man and it's a great show still
nothing good it still makes me well the
tide could change for somebody so fast
yeah and you know what I think it did I
think there was a there was a I'm not I
don't know about comedians now but there
was a dynamic of comedians that
were
you just wished [ __ ] would do
bad like back then like everybody was
wishing everybody if you saw The Tonight
Show dudes would be watching to watch a
dude eat it you know they're like and
why did you think that is
I just think it was like like that crabs
in the barrel that they pull the dude
they pull the dudes down and there was
no social media so you heard about a
dude and then you saw him oh my God and
then just it just became this kind of
[ __ ] Cesspool of just now did you
find yourself uh that um do you regret
your part in that you know what I
actually
got out of it like one year like
98. so there's three years of just
really dark times at 98 New Year's Eve I
was just like you know
I'm gonna I'm not worried about more
about myself than about everybody else
and everybody just they should be a even
a paper called Just for Laughs where it
had
this is a paper that you could get at a
comedy club and they would have things
that dudes were doing and when people
would see that they'd be like ah [ __ ]
him and uh that's called Instagram now
right so when I decided to let that go I
think everything changed like I really I
always used to feel like the Latino
comedy community like it was like it was
like they were playing King of the Hill
you know like it had to be only one at
the top right at a time so it was like
you know whoever you know then no one
else could be up there it has to be this
one guy and then like as if there wasn't
enough for everybody right sure exactly
no hmm I laugh at all of them I don't
care
Latino black white you're funny I
laughed yeah yeah
so um what type of Father do you think
you would be we'll see I'm trying
you know I'm trying to be an old ass dad
have you gone and get checked yeah I'm
doing it yeah I mean that's funny you
said I'm in the process of that now you
know what I mean so we'll see because
you how do they how do they have you
started it have they
have you started to go to a fertility
maybe yeah well they have they they do
it different now now you could just
something comes in the mail
yeah man yeah then they'll test it out
over there then I remember I was when I
had a vasectomy you had to get busted
out in the bag in the tube and take it
in I took it into the hospital and
you're kind of embarrassed now here here
it is my calm and and right here and I
waited in line and I said here it is Oh
wrong line you got to see me you got to
go over here to that night in front of
everybody she might as well go on a loud
speaker we got a semen sample over here
now too we needed to be an out seven
what do you think that you know
I mean I only have one one daughter and
you know I try to have more and and I
what I would tell animals you know I
spent so many years trying to get
someone not pregnant that you know
it's like how do you turn the [ __ ]
boat around hang on
you're not pregnant thank God
it's like it used to be so like visible
yeah what the Earth was about it's like
God puts it in God takes it out girl
dude dude's like oh my God what are you
gonna do now and then it becomes I think
hormonal and then you know for the guy
marrow hormone
normal wipe your dick on her business
but then you know ovulation kits and all
that stuff is well now my my wife has an
app you know so there's an app that
tracks so she'll tell me like huh yeah
um
so this is like actually get home
we are at seven days actually starting
today it was like this is like and
you're wasting your time here
last night I put it in you know what I
mean so we'll see but you put it in
there with a purple listen it's not like
it's not recreational [ __ ] it's like
[ __ ] with a person no now it's like a
job which I don't like you know what I
mean so it's like you know do they do
that [ __ ] like they did
I like to take her legs
I'm trying to yeah I'm trying to shake
it up
we gotta make this stick is there a way
like nobody moves after you
yeah I try to Stir It Up do they say do
they do they send ways to like uh to to
do it or or
insemination I mean no but I'm sure
there is a I'm sure there is yeah
you were killing him
he's got kids
it's three legitimate
what does that mean legitimate well I
don't know where there any place else
remember I was I was out of the country
for when I was a kid I got married
what how long
when I got out of the army
I had three goals in life one to go to
college one to become a cop because that
cop saved my life that's why I turned
around and number three I wanted to hook
up with my girlfriend that my
ex-girlfriend that had written me a Dear
John in Vietnam
and I wanted to hook her get her back
eating out of the palm of my hand and
then break it off in her because I
wanted Revenge I just I used to be a big
deal
I was I was full of full of bitterness
wasn't it oh yeah be nice to him get him
back [ __ ] them and then be like get the
[ __ ] out of here yeah then I want to
remember [ __ ] you I didn't want that I
got out in June of 70 by September 70
had her eaten out of the palm of my hand
December 26 1970 we got married
also and it's been 51 years I lost two
out of three two out of three I won the
third one 91 years there wow that's
great man so and then three kids we're
still we're still doing it uh um and we
didn't have to ovulate or take messages
they didn't have and they didn't have
apps for it then either but but but as a
guy gets you just Latino
yeah
that's what's wrong with you
you're probably a [ __ ] dude hey let
me try yeah guys guys listen I'm trying
to have I mean it's actually harder than
people think too but but it should be
because uh we're already overpopulated
does the potency of sperm have a a end
date is it older you get no because
dudes are like intercepted [ __ ] yeah
but you still have to be making sure
you're taking care of yourself having
the proper vitamins there are certain
vitamins and mineral and supplements and
things that'll keep you you know active
and
you know isn't it crazy man like you
know my [ __ ] chalks or One A Day
vitamin that people used to think that
that was it chalks was like remember
chalk it was like kid vitamins
my family never afforded vitamin we
didn't have [ __ ] when I was like yeah
yeah but I bet you if they examined like
like the type of food that you get you
ate I mean there's like you know I'm
sure there's all I ever heard was eat
pineapple in your semen tastes sweet
it does taste sweet
well he kisses his wife after
that's
that's uh yeah they don't even do that
in porn no thanks no I I don't know this
is just you are what you eat but but uh
the uh what did I eat
um but there's nothing like there's
there's nothing like seeing your your
baby come out
you know I'm so ready for all I wish
that for you yeah I am I'm ready for all
that right everything it does change you
know what's funny is like I have already
been thinking about this so one thing
that really did touch me was when we
were on that Zoom call for that audition
and you were like this I'm working with
my daughter and I thought oh how great
is that oh like it's like it's like it
really is great you know what I mean so
it's because it's like you did this and
then now she's following in the
Footsteps in her own way so I thought oh
man this is what I missed out on you
know so I'm like but it really is very
special I mean you think about
I mean I was there I cut the cord you
know I walked down the hall with her I
did the whole the whole thing and then
you and then well being over there at
NBC and we're doing this this scene and
you're looking at her
and you're just like wow man I'm taking
this journey with this young lady here
you know and and part of and she's not
on a pole you know what I mean
I'll tell them to
their lights on so I'm the pilot
this is a show I didn't book by the way
but didn't I say I auditioned and then
you know but but nobody out but but
didn't I say that when I got you wanted
though did not didn't I tell you you
wanted him right yeah why was I
auditioning that's what I want to ask
future of it he's picked up but didn't I
tell everybody how much I admired you
yeah yeah you did I did right yeah no I
I mean you know I'm just it's just the
competitive bitter actor in me right oh
no like but I mean I wanted the pot but
you know how I I mean the thing about
the thing that works for me in these
shows like this show is that
as well adjusted you're well adjusted
I'm not so in the show I want you guys
to tell me where I've gone wrong and
what I should do with my life and I
think that's the angle of the show that
I want to bring right is guys older that
you are you too old to get it right and
that's I'm the one that doesn't know the
other one the first show The Ernie
character was a guy that I was helping I
was like the big brother and in this one
you guys are well adjusted and I'm not I
like that you know and the friends get
along with the ex-wife where I'm like
what the [ __ ] you guys talking about
she's great she's funny and she's you
know beautiful and just like what you
know you just kind of
um you're I'm lying on your own Island
yeah I like it I should be your
therapist on this show yeah I think it
would be awesome right you come see me
weekly or whatever it is like that right
right Daddy no we did that yeah no it'd
be hilarious that that to me that's all
and in a way that guys are now as they
get older the thing that the male we
used to get back then was that a guy
would watched the show with his daughter
and she was at an age where the daughter
starts to leave you know and then they
would watch the show together and he's
like I got my baby back before you know
they start to grow up and goes and I
think that this could be an opportunity
of the show to be able to do that that's
good man I'm glad I was you know I think
that in uh um there's a certain amount
of jealousy and envy that I think is
okay as long as it's not in a negative
place you know but I think as long as
you use it to inspire yourself so I
think this like when you see someone
else doing something it's okay to be
like damn I wish that was me right but
congratulations on that and I think that
that's the things that we've made and
that's how I thought about when I saw
that I was like that show got picked up
yeah you know because when you don't get
the part you're like you know
no but I was like I was glad that you
know also what you know you're talking
about me 20 years later I was [ __ ]
green is green back then and I would I
was trying to work hard so that we had a
place to go every day yeah yeah for 120
episodes because you know the first time
that the show aired the first Wednesday
that it aired there was a thing in the
L.A times and it said is this the one
and it looked like a like it would be a
an article that was encouraging and the
first you know side of the page wasn't
then you turn the page to the like page
four and then the rest of it isn't so
then when I went to work you could sense
that it was the day of the premiere of
the show and you could sense that we
were rehearsing and people were like
so I said hey I took everybody in the uh
in the makeup room close the door and I
showed them the paper and I said listen
you see this doesn't matter we're gonna
go and we're gonna perform and we're
gonna do our thing on based on on people
not based on yeah on writers yeah and
now 20 years later
you know and have your mind there and
again I feel the same I'm smarter than I
was 20 years ago yeah and I know like
the angles to take to be able to have
people watch the show and still be funny
but also be something that
I've unsafe it seems kind of crazy to
say redeeming but to get somebody to
think about you know why would I put you
on the show why would I put l on the
show to to bring out the things that
were inadequate in myself but inadequate
in people that are watching as well yeah
you know what's funny too is that
um you know we're living a world now
we're like you want you want to talk
about a useless profession critic right
you know we don't need it anymore right
we don't need it the reason is is
because now people can go to the
internet and now like somebody can 100
000 people can watch your show and they
go online and they go I liked it I liked
it I liked it so now I have a sample
size of a large number of people are
telling me that they like this show
right who are like me right as opposed
to a uppity
why are they deciding that why are they
the taste makers so when I look at these
things and I see like this is always a
sign to me it'll be like like let's say
it's you know one out of ten right so
it'll be like critics gave this a six
but the audience gave it a nine
give me give me the nine yeah sure yeah
I am you know it's true you know and
then there's some guys that just there
was a guy at the USA Today this guy
Robert Bianco I don't think he's
probably not there anymore but this dude
it would be like never missed an
opportunity to take a shot at me
I mean never in the and I mean
I remember being on a plane and when
American Idol came out
I mean and somebody had to be against
them and I was against American Idol the
last three years that the show was on
and survived I mean they just went they
were just killing people man I mean
people were watching the second half
hour American Idol with the results yeah
just killing shows and I survived
because I had laid down enough of a
foundation where people
would still tune in right right right
and even beat them in some places right
and that's oh that's what I'm hoping for
for this yeah yeah so make sure you
watch it coming to NBC right and no
shows got picked up I mean this was a
crazy I know Season man no shows got
picked up
overall and they canceled shows with
huge Stars man like there's there's no
uh I'm a reason to this now and there's
no then there's no kind of you know you
put money in the bank they're gonna look
at you and say you know we'll take care
Ted Danson got canceled from [ __ ] NBC
and he was on the good life and he did
Cheers and it's like they're like hey
sorry we're gonna pick up your show
matter yeah there's no more
kind of a handshake don't worry you'll
be all right it's just it's just good
for you man I'm glad I'm happy for you
dude you know you're still in it you're
still in it man I'm in it man you're
still relevant and then I watched uh you
know Sanford and Son growing up who I
mean amazing yeah and that's the time
spot I got oh that's Friday at eight you
with young rock my favorite my favorite
thing from Sanford and Son was always
you like a lollipop all days
they were so [ __ ] I know those shows
are just 98 o'clock and I get I get to
hang with you you get to come to the
yeah you get to come to Eric will be
there yeah we're gonna we're gonna work
this out let's go yeah yeah but anyways
um I don't know this has been is this I
appreciate you coming in yeah man I feel
like that we we get to a good stopping
wasn't it great it was great yeah it's
good to sit with you man this is another
thing I was going to say about what's
great about podcasts in what world
in the circumstance where you and I
would sit down and chat like this for an
hour no it it just it's not a thing that
just would happen you know yeah and it's
like you kind of see people in passing
and it's like it takes a long time
sometimes you just catch it a certain
time like that night you just happened
to see me was just because you guys have
been hanging out it was you DL and
whatever and you guys were there with
Reuben and right and you just have to be
like let me watch this guy for a second
and that's just how it goes you wait but
this is what's great about this format
man so just to sit down with someone who
you know I've admired for many years
I've seen I know about you I've seen you
I've been like you know it's like from
afar you know it's like you know you're
one of the dignitaries of the you know
the business and and now here we are
sitting down chopping it up for an hour
like two regular dudes yeah so it's
great I really appreciate it
you know what I wish I did I went one
time I went no let me let me explain to
my golf store okay
golf is fun when you first start when
you go to a par three course yes and
you're like you know what this is kind
of fun then I went to one of those big
and I was like just I I can't I can't do
it I don't I don't have that in me it's
just not what is it like is it is it
like going into the jungle like you see
a real life yeah yeah you're like ah
damn you know what and I've been to some
celebrity ones I've done it but I only
go nine I just go I'm out man yeah cause
like that ball where is it you know what
they used to be a great [ __ ] comedian
golf tournament
uh in uh almost like in in Palos Verdes
out there where all the comedians played
like guys would fly in and they don't do
it anymore you need to do it again who's
that dude from the Bay Area would come
back because Chris Spencer is always you
can link up with Chris Spencer yeah
I'm doing it when it's like and it
didn't even matter if a dude could play
or not yeah you know yeah I've done so
many I mean like one time I I was on a
celebrity and it was me and like Omarosa
we're on the same team
[Laughter]
and I was like what am I doing here you
know what I mean so but you know as an
advocate for
for you know I've been playing golf
forever I got Michael Clarke Duncan
golfing I would see him at the Laker
games I'd say hey man come and play golf
he was dating Emma Russell and he played
golf and he loved pass unfortunately
yeah but he loved he just found
something that he loved yeah I get it
though I get but you know golf reminds
me a lot of stand-up comedy where it's
like you are really not competing with
these other people right you're
competing with the course and you're
you're trying to get you know better
numbers for yourself each time even
though all these people are on the
scoreboard that scoreboard has nothing
to do with people competing against each
other as they are competing against this
thing that you you could be doing great
up to you're doing great you're doing
great I'm gonna win this right and then
you bogey right right so it's like
that's about it's about you know staying
focused and staying committed and being
and being like you know uh consistent
and that's why it's really very much
like can I tell you where's your part of
the story yeah please so where's your
priority live done
um Parthenia in Northridge it's a
Wrigley estate the Wrigley gum estate
right and Jennifer uh Pryor told me this
and he had Uncle dickie from the pool
hall back in Peoria so Uncle Dickie
comes in and he's limping and Uncle
Dickey was a pimp you know and he ran a
pool hall in Peoria and he was out there
now Richard brought the family out here
and Uncle Dickie comes into the house
and he gets out and Richard and Jennifer
on the port they go inside and he takes
his shoe off and he's got this blue foot
you know and he's like Rich look at my
foot and so rich is sitting in this
chair and Jennifer sitting on the arm of
the chair and he goes I need an
operation Rich look at my foot
and it's just you just got diabetes you
know you might lose his foot so so
Jennifer says give him the money Richard
and Richard Pryor goes [ __ ] you're
supposed to be talking me out of it
doesn't the wife always so he gives them
50 Grand to get to get his surgery next
time they see him he rolls up in a
[ __ ] Cadillac white with a red
interior
under each arm helping him walk that was
that was his answer
that was his answer to my foot's [ __ ]
up get me get it let me get a Cadillac
with a red interior with a woman under
each other helping me walk up yeah
definitely he was one of uh One of a
Kind yeah it was a great documentary
that did you see that documentary yeah I
think so you saw it wasn't you know what
was fascinating about it I didn't
realize all that stuff that was going on
how difficult his life was and how like
you know the drugs and all this stuff
and how it derailed like whatever might
have been an even greater career right
it was very like we don't know we don't
know people no you really you know we
don't know what's going on in people's
lives but you know
wow I mean it's a that dude was like my
the
Dalai Lama of the um yeah I would say
that that was the only he was the first
person my grandmother LED in the house
by VHS
I love you man thank you and I'll see
you on my show yeah I hope I'll tell you
I'm gonna tell you it was a pleasure
you're awesome Eric pleasure I wish you
the best and I wish you the best in your
marriage and also working on your and
you're doing it trying to bust inside
it's a beautiful [ __ ] yeah don't say it
like a prison